Dave Grohl is definitely not ordinary
yes the Foo Fighters front man is doing
his part to feed the less fortunate
working for over 24 hours last week to
cook for hundreds of people in need at
the Hope mission in Los Angeles
[Music]
[Applause]
in the midst of the California storms
last week they provided over 500 meals
that he paid for and cooked on his very
own smoker the meals included ribs pork
butt brisket cabbage coleslaw and beans
and according to TMZ he managed to get
some sleep here and there in the parking
lot while the meat was getting smoked
and the singer also took time to chat
with staff members and guests staying at
the shelter a middle school
anytime you want to do some barbecue you
can get back there and help next time
you're in the kitchen